[Music]
hello hi thank you so much for that
amazing introduction so hey everyone my
name is Shirley and this is Letty and
we're to data visualization freelancers
from Amsterdam in San Francisco and for
the last 10 months we've been working on
a project called data sketches where we
take a topic each month and visualize it
by around the end of the month so let's
start from the very beginning Nani and I
actually met online in a private data
visualization slag and the fall of 2015
and didn't actually meet each other in
person until open viscom in Boston last
year where we had the pleasure of giving
talks separately and hang out for three
whole days where we got along really
well so that when two months later Nadi
put up her as VG tutorials accompanying
her talks I give them into them with
vigor and as I started talking to Nadi
with questions about her tutorials
restarted somehow commiserating around
the fact that we really hadn't completed
as many data visualization side projects
as we were hoping for in the past year
and that was when I had an idea and I
asked Nani fully expecting to be
rejected do you want to collaborate with
me and then she said yes and that's how
they discussed started so in the
following week we fear doubt that we
both like the idea where we would create
a visualization around a specific topic
each month and do that for a year to see
how two people would create two
visualizations starting from the same
seed the topic and then diverging into
different paths based on our own
interest in history well besides sharing
the end result we also want to write
about the creation process
and we split this up into the three
pillars that we find most important data
sketches and coding and initially we
thought we could pull data sketches off
with about five to six hours a week but
yeah as usual real life doesn't really
care about your plans especially coding
plans so since starting in July 2016
we've clocked many many hours into
creating a visualization each month and
during this talk we'd like to take you
through some of the lessons that we
learned the challenges that we face now
we can tackle them and the insights that
we gathered along the way so let's start
with the data we often get asked this
question do you get your idea you get
your data first and then come up with
the idea or do you get your ideas first
and for the two of us the answer is
always always idea first so for example
for our November data sketches I
visualized every single line in the
musical called Hamilton and built a tool
where I can filter by any set of
characters their conversations and
phrases and then be able to dig into all
of the lyrics that were left in the
remaining song and the question I
started with was this how do the
relationship change between the
characters as a musical progresses and
what are the recurring phrases and who
are they associated with now as you can
probably imagine this data was not
available online anywhere so I had to go
through each of those lyrics noting
every single time a phrase occurred
across more than one song group those
phrases into themes and then go through
the lyrics again entering them into the
computer and associating them with the
right song and line number and gene
exact same thing for the characters and
conversations and then I wrote a script
to aggregate those characters in themes
by their song and line number to get my
final data set
in a more extreme example I asked
October decided that I wanted to put
emojis on mr. and mrs. Obama faces so I
have here every YouTube video um that
you can dig through of their late-night
talk show appearances and here you can
go home through each of the scenes click
on any of the frames and see their faces
on Oh the images are not loading but if
they load it then you can see the faces
um oh no oh there we go yeah so emojis
on their faces
[Music]
thank you this skill brings me joy I did
this for the election because it was
bumming me out
and then this still brings me joy um so
the idea really started with when I was
talking to one of our friends Eric and
he said wouldn't it be cool if you could
run facial detection on the videos and
correlate their emotions with what
they're saying and I was like hey Eric
you realize I only have one month to do
this and then I was like you know what
Eric
challenge accepted so to do this I had
to manually first gather all of the late
night talk show appearances also by NVB
get their corresponding YouTube videos
also their hosts channels use a node
package to download all the videos and
their captions so that I can get the
timestamps from the closed captions to
take a screenshot every time somebody
talks and then upload them to the Google
vision API which is a really fun API
that gives me like the bounds of their
faces as well as data about like whether
or not each of these people were like
happy or angry or sad or was wearing a
hat and and gave that data back to me in
a JSON format back then I cleared the
write a script to aggragate with the
caption data to get my final data set
[Laughter]
it would be too kind of extreme examples
taught me was that if I have a curiosity
and curiosity that I can get the data is
out there somehow whether I have to go
manually gather them or write a bunch of
automated scripts which by the way I
found that there is like a new library
for anything I can imagine Under the Sun
as long as I play responsibly and
legally so thankfully not every month
this is data intensive I surely just
showed us this are more normal months
and with places you can find data online
for example for August I decided to dive
into the Olympics well our theme with
the Olympics because it is rather
obvious and we are both expense and I
wanted to visualize all 5,000 gold medal
winners since the very first Olympic
Games in 1896 so each of these circles
is a group of similar sports like water
sports or ball sports and then each of
the slices or feathers within a circle
is one sport Langguth Olympics and then
we have the first version going out or
2016 the reddish background are female
events the blueish background are male
events and finally the color of each of
these medals is the confidence in which
the country lies that won the medal so
for example Europe is blue and America's
is red and so on we can see that at the
very first editions there were no female
ethics events but we've been catching up
since then thankfully and I found the
data set for this piece from two
articles published by the Guardian for
the 2012 Games in London
however after getting a rough shape of
my visual on the screen I noticed some
very obvious medals from missing from
2012 like hockey so suddenly my
confidence in his dataset dropped
drastically and I had to get a sense of
the actual accuracy of his dataset but I
didn't want to have to manually go
through all 5,000 medals myself manually
although I'm still wondering if surely
it would not have
so I found a proxy instead and on
Wikipedia I could find a number of
events that occurred for each of the
editions and I could compare that to the
number of gold medals I had in my data
set and they proposed the discrepancy I
dug deeper to figure out where and why
and that's how I found out that for some
of the years the horses were also in the
dataset winning gold which makes for an
interesting read assembly see princess
and [ __ ] and lady Mirka as women
winning gold in the Olympics well
finally I figured out each discrepancy
and made adjustments to my data to get
it to the point where I trusted it again
and my lesson here was that even coming
from such a respectable source as the
Guardian I really need to get a sense of
accuracy and completeness of my data
because missing data can be harder to
find them wrong data you don't always
have to check every value but think
about taking sums and counts and
averages and comparing these two plain
common sense or even better at different
data source so many people jump straight
from data as a final visual but take
some time and sit back and sketch out
your ideas instead we filled many pages
of our notebooks in starting because
sketching helps us think and layout
ideas beforehand and my sketches are
often very simple and I really only
focus on the main abstract shapes then I
want to fit my data into like colors and
layout and details these are things I
only vaguely think about but don't act
on until I have the data on my screen
there's just no use to think about these
things until I figured out that the data
works once I've morphed it into the
final shape and for the Olympics for
example I had this idea of feathers
placing more emphasis on the recent
additions however I had no idea that
would look a white when I finally placed
all 5,000 medals together
I have to see the general shape woodwork
before moving on so I started laying out
the feathers and it took a few steps but
if I eventually I came to the point
where I saw that luckily it did show
potential with the actual data but
sometimes there is no use of start
sketching on paper although I will say
that forever but networks an exception
for me and for October my
thing to dive into was royalty versus
the Obamas and I've always been
intrigued by how into marriage the
Royals really are you know are they old
cousins twice removed and luckily I
found a genealogy data set that
contained a gigantic family tree as a
European royal houses it was from 1992
so I have to add one or two more
generations in the main line of
succession which was a fun night on
Wikipedia but so here we have the family
three or 3,000 people and the current
royal leaders are the big circles and
everybody is connected to their parents
their partner and their children and to
highlight the interconnections you can
actually hover over anybody and see how
far their six degrees of separation
would lead into the web and you can also
click on anybody see if that works here
and anybody else to see the shortest
path between these two people because
the entire web is connected well but
when I started out with this data set I
had no idea what it contained
so I just put everybody on the page
using the most basic network settings
and this happened an explosion of points
on lines going out of my screen well
let's reign in gravity bit then but that
left me with a useless hairball well
maybe I could color them by year first
no not helping but luckily in decreased
version while the newest version you can
have gravity depend on variables so I
pulled the web apart by year of birth as
well that was better but it was still a
rather unentitled bundle and at this
point I'd already invested several hours
into playing with the network settings
playing with the different kinds of
connection adjusting my data and I was
really ready to just give up but you
know I gave it one last time and this
time I decided to focus on the current
Royal leaders so I please these in a
line and then I let the vertebral
gravity depend on how you know which of
these recurrent royal leaders you were
most closely related to and that's when
I finally saw it insight for example
that the Queen of Denmark over here is
actually very central to the web whereas
the princes monocle line here is
separated from the rest more than two
hundred year
ago and it was only around this time
that I finally started thinking about
the more of the design aspects and
networks often reminds me of
constellations and with my astronomy
background I have a bias rolling space
so I turned it into a starry night and
the thing is I could have never designed
this visualization beforehand I had to
go hand in hand the actual data and
apply my design choices to all of the
data simultaneously to see if the
results are both engaging and insightful
so now you gave us a really great
example of when we land on the right
visualization form early on in our
process but that's not always the case
so for our March data schedules we had
the incredible opportunity to work with
the Google News lab and their search
data dating back to 2004 and with access
to this incredible amount of data I
wanted to take a look at what countries
searched for around the world for travel
across each different seasons and for a
particular country I wanted to be able
to see for each of those topics what are
the search interests across the years
and their seasonality patterns but to
get to this point I first asked what are
the top search countries and it turns
out it's Brazil and then I wondered
who's searching for Brazil what are the
kind of topics are is being searched for
for Brazil and each of those countries
and what are the distributions like
across each of the years and then I
wondered can I put search interests in
there somehow
which did not turn out so well I call
this my plunder theory so I took a step
back and I say ok so maybe I can try out
circles as each of those topics and show
the search interest as a radius of each
circle and for each country searching
for that topic
I'll have overlapping circles and this
is what it looked like and I thought it
looked pretty ok
it's kind of pretty so then I wondered
well I think I noticed that maybe
geography plays a part in who's
searching for a country
topics within the country so maybe I can
try sorting those topics for particular
year by distance and that didn't look so
great so then I was like maybe I can
just concentrate on one topic across the
years and that looks like maybe it will
lend nicely to a heat map like ha this
is not going anywhere
and then but then I remembered that
earlier on in my explorations I had
noticed that there's a lot of
seasonality in a lot of the topics so
then I wondered can i filter and group
each of those topics by each of the
seasons and maybe the sounded kind of
promising like maybe I'll be able to get
some insights out of this and nope it
turns out that each of those topics are
searched for across all of the seasons
which meant that each of the graphs
actually looked exactly the same I was
really disappointed but then but then I
remembered by hey the search interests
are different across each of the seasons
which means that if I decides the height
of each of those blogs by the search
interest then I can start getting
insights like this one but the United
States searches for travel more often in
the spring than in the fall so finally
finally Tuggle the final visualization
where each of the blog's that represent
a topic group by their country and I can
toggle between the seasons and see
insights like for example that Mexico
search interests is low in the summer
but the Canada is high and the same is
true for the hotter countries around the
world like the Thailand and the
Philippines but when I toggle to winter
the opposite is true and I can see that
Mexico Peaks where Canada drops and
Thailand and the Philippines have peaked
also so the lesson I learned is that
sometimes we don't get the right
visualization for the data on our first
or a second or even third sketch so be
patient and go back and forth with the
sketching code to figure out what works
and more importantly what doesn't work
so we can figure out where to go next
so as expected most of our hours are
spent on actually getting the data on
the screen and here are some of our may
be less obvious coding lessons for our
very first month the topic was moving
and for me it was immediately clear I
wanted to do something with the Lord of
the Rings and I found this amazing data
set that contained the number of words
spoken by each character in each scene
of all three extended editions of the
lore the Rings and how amazing is that I
knew I had to visualize that and I
decided to focus on the troubleshoot
member so how much have each member of
the Fellowship spoken at the different
locations that we have on site here well
no surprise maybe if Gandalf says the
most but my favorite insight was that
Boromir who is really only alive during
one movie manages to speak more than
Legolas does in three I didn't know that
anyways here is a sketch of my project
and when I saw it I found that it was
very similar looking to a chord diagram
so I decided to start from there and
then slowly transform the chord diagram
into my sketch and here we have a
typical chord diagram and the most
fundamental thing to me was is if I
could figure out how to get each inner
inner chords to flow towards the center
which actually took less time than
anticipated which is very rare for me in
coding but getting rid of the space and
now it was ready to handle the actual
Lord of the Rings data in some more
appropriate colors well we asked nine
members of the fellowship so I have to
make sure the center's end up at the
right vertical location but now is
getting very squished so I just pulled
the two halves apart but these chords
they are looking kind of unnatural right
now and that's when I decided to finally
dive into SVG paths and learn how to
make them myself
it took a while but it was really an
improvement on these chords how they
looked finally and that's how I sort of
ended up with this new kind of chart
that mutated from the chord diagram and
many people have done the wonderful work
that you can use so even if you are
creating something new you don't always
have to start
scratch just pick the thing the life
most closely to your design or idea and
start adjusting that you know remix was
out there already but sometimes
sometimes we managed to dream up things
are unique enough where there is no base
for us to remix office for that same
month of movies I wanted to look at the
top summer blockbusters of the past two
decades and reimagine them as flowers so
each of the colors represent a different
genre and the number and the size and
the number of petals of the flowers
correspond to the I am there at IMDb
rateing and so we have some really
beautiful ones in here like The Dark
Knight Rises and inception and Slumdog
Millionaire but my absolute absolute
favorite is the 1997 Batman and Robin
because it's so teeny-tiny so cute
I think it's so cute and I gotten that
uh and we've gotten really great
responses for this and people have asked
me how did you make this visualization
how long did it take you and the answer
is actually that it's actually really
simple and straightforward and all it
takes is a good grasp of the SVG path
and in particular the cubic Bezier curve
command and so how that works is we
start with a point in this case 0 0 and
the way that I like to think about it is
that we draw a line from that starting
point to the ending purple point and
then we take the blue and green anchor
points and nudge them out until we get
the curve that we want we draw a line to
line or I draw two lines and then make
the same a curve on the other side
rotate the petals out and then add in
the colors and those it and so really
understand the tools that you're using
because with that understanding we can
really go beyond the prescribed examples
of pre-existing examples that are out
there ready and then the particular
of all of the tools that we use as a
sheep as is probably our favorite
because with a good grasp of SVG path we
can make any shape that we dream up for
truly truly unique results
so besides SVG paths we've also had a
lot of fun playing with math in the past
few months and as my addition to the
collaboration month with Google News lab
I decided to dive into translations so
what have other languages translated to
English we're going from the most
translated words for 10 chosen languages
like German and Dutch and more to the
top 10 most translated words down to the
similarities between languages and here
each of the lines between two languages
represents one word that these two
languages have in common between their
top 10 at first I wanted to replace all
of these lines with the actual words
that they represent well yeah then I
actually saw it and a complete mess it's
way too busy so it took a few iterations
to finally get to this more focused and
clear version but one of the most
important things here was that these
words over here we're all as upright as
possible for readability but that turned
into some convoluted calculations for
you to get these text paths which became
glaringly obvious once I click one of
these circles which moves it to the
center yeah that wasn't quite how you
might have expected it to go so I needed
to figure out how to fix that and that's
where math and rational problem solving
came to the rescue
yeah it took a few pages out of my
notebook but eventually I figured out
how to implement the solution so now if
I click any of these languages it is
more like somebody would expect it to go
but I what I've done is really more of a
hack maybe because once you click one of
these circles the words they are faded
out and then I immediately replace all
of these lines with their final states
but I prefer engineered them to their
previous state and then smoothly
transition them to the final state so my
lesson here was I guess I knew it
already but if you are
doing something new definitely expect
that it will take time because you are
going to encounter struggles and if you
didn't already learn to love math
because it is usually your best friend
in solving these kinds of visual
problems so thus far we've talked about
the what I like to call the first 80%
the data preparation the ideation the
sketching and the visualization is self
but there's the rest of the 20% but
details that we find really important
also so when I started thinking about
the story for Hamilton I knew that I
wanted it to reach a wider audience than
usual and I knew I wanted them to be
engaged enough to keep scrolling down
the screen so the very first thing I did
was on page load there is all of the
dots fly into the center to create the
Hamilton logo and as the users start
scrolling down the screen the dots
fly apart and then dance around until
they get pulled back in together so that
I can show the reader that he each of
these dots are actually Fowler and as
the reader Scrolls into the first
section of analysis each of these
sections are actually corresponding with
one of the songs so then I highlight the
write corresponding song for them the
other thing that I did is that if the
user decides they want to click on one
of the songs oh there's no way reduce
no audio okay well believe me when I say
that there's a song playing somewhere in
there and so as you can see there's a
progress bar that I highlight I'm in the
visualization in the right so that the
user can get a sense of where the song
is that's playing that relative to the
rest of the musical another example a
smaller example that I want to show you
is that for that same month of travel I
have these sections where I animate how
to read different sections of the
visualizations
but I don't start the animations until
the user Scrolls down into the correct
section so that no matter how quickly or
slowly they scroll they can always see
the animation from start to beginning
and it's really these small attention to
detail and the temps that delight that
really make a piece for me because it
tells the reader that we really care
about their experience and even more
examples of things you could do with the
light well all slides back to answer
them actually from CSS combs in
Melbourne I decided to make I hope if it
ever gets to the next page I have to
[Music]
there we go yeah right so I didn't have
any Wi-Fi and you know what ten thousand
feet so I couldn't do anything essential
and I decided to just create an animated
legend of my visualisation about fantasy
books you know for fun and or adding
animated gifs of the most memorable and
fun moments in Dragonball Z or having a
hopper with the most detailed
information I had for music nerves in my
December music visual or turning the top
ten songs into tiny vinyls having
annotations about sphere appeared weird
and silly events of the Olympic Games
like Henry piers having to stop for
ducks in the rowing event but still
managing to win gold you know although
getting your data on the screen in such
a manner as to make it insightful is key
it's the extra things to add like
animations annotations we're at Legends
gifts and more that will make it unique
and special and even more of a delight
to investigate so take some time to
think about these aspects as well so
finally finally we get to the salsa or
what I like to call the best stuff so
when Maddie and I started talking about
this project but we really weren't
expecting the kind of response we got we
thought that if we could just have fun
and maybe you learn some things and if
our friends enjoyed it then that'd be
enough and that'd be really cool but
instead we've gotten them the most
amazing feedback both about our
visualizations and the
value of our write-up and we've had the
opportunity to meet some amazing
credible people and talk to them and
even gain an unexpectedly great
friendship out of all of this but when
we really sat back to think about the
transferable lessons the most important
thing that we agreed on is that if
you're about to embark on an ambitious
project grab someone to go along the
ride with you because then you can
motivate and support each other when
things get tough and make sure that that
someone you grab is if you're not so
responsible yourself but it's someone
very responsible so that you can keep
each other accountable and relatively on
track and because you don't want to eat
let each other down make sure that
someone you grab is someone you really
respect and hopefully the few who use
mutual you respect each other and but
most importantly that someone is someone
you trust or can grow to trust because
that's absolutely essential to giving
and receiving feedback and finally can
we talk about to do something ambitious
like make a data visualization from
scratch every single month and know that
it's going to be hard and we've been
creatively drained we see there was a
month where we've been creatively
drained and we didn't know how to go on
just remember you learn as you struggle
and the amount that we've learned both
personally and technically have been
absolutely amazing and very much worth
the time so over the last 10 months
we've learned to find data and the
weirdest of places that you can sketch
the weed out thinking errors but that
you can also sketch with code that SVG
paths and math are amazing but we really
knew that of course
and that surprisingly small things can
Edinson to delight to your audience and
we did set out to learn or we can funded
by all these things like Shirley said we
set out to have fun and then that would
definitely succeed it sure it's been
tough there were times when we were
coding into the night when we would have
rather bench the TV show but it had
opened up new paths and opportunities
that we were
you're looking for so we hope that
you'll join us in our final two months
of data munging sketching and coding up
our topics into fun weird and overtly
elaborate visualizations thank you very
much very magic oh how is that Donna
sketched yes
[Applause]